hi guys uh my little sluggy trash bags i
am going to be at zany's in chicago
tonight and tomorrow
check me out there i'm going to be at
hilarity's in cleveland ohio september
9th through 11th i'm bringing josh
potter i'm going to be at the life is
beautiful festival in las vegas
september 18th and 19th i'm going to be
in how do you guys say it rayleigh riley
everyone's mad at me for saying it wrong
raleigh raleigh we'll spell it different
raleigh north carolina good night
september 23rd through 25th i'm going to
hopefully then be in
hawaii with kalila i'm going to be at
the comedy works in denver october 14th
and 16th san antonio laugh out loud
october 22nd and 23rd and a lot more
other dates at annieletterman.com check
it out you can get some of my merch come
see me sluggish we've been having so
much fun it's crazy
hi slugs i'm not here today but i wanted
to let you know i have a new drop at
sleepoverbyester.com it's the
enchantment under the sea dance look and
i'm also coming to san francisco and
portland those tickets are going fast so
go to esteronites.com if you're coming
to see me and
enjoy the slug queens
[Music]
i'm excited
i've been waiting a long time
since day one to just come on and just
see your the the flavor the spices
watch the lifestyle unfold instantly can
i give you a nickname big ester
let's go proud proudly
big ass sir
we're the same esther you look beautiful
today thank you so much
more showered than usual i didn't even
shower this morning i was in a hot tub
last night so i felt good enough not to
shout that's so disgusting and perfect
for our show yeah
let the beans soak a bit you know
a couple people whose hot tub were you
in
my buddy benny's
no benny maddie and benny maddy and
benny yeah do you have friends that
don't have an e sound at the end of the
room annie
george
no just i hang out with just wise
it's easier that way i have to confront
kalyana right now do you [ __ ] botox
where
okay i'm tan [ __ ] i just came from home
it would be fine if you did but you look
a little snatched i
because that's what why would you be mad
it's a compliment you know george said
the same thing to me after i got back
from hawaii he was like you for once
look beautiful what if what
for once is nice what if kalaila is nice
they get botox in hawaii you never went
to hawaii
it was all a green screen and that you
just went to go get all snatched up
imagine if it was a medical vacation you
look great thank you so much beautiful
right as she was sparing a fish it
speared her yeah
i did see a monk seal they're critically
endangered i am the last one
of that sperm the sperm aren't monk
seals not allowed to have sex
because i raised my hand for that one
the dad jokes are back
but thank you so much annie
you're you really are and by the way tan
isn't you're i'm i'm tan that's what it
is
this is what it is it's what it is it's
what it is maddie you're also
maddie taking a hot tub bath is the
funniest thing i've ever heard
now
i'm thinking about that
how
how long will you go without the shower
after the after the tomorrow well i'm
gonna go in the hot tub later you're
canadian yeah i heard it near tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow so you live here what
but you live here no you live in canada
canada don't eat us well mayor it's a
bit much
the uh i live in uh ridgeway but here's
the thing your
healthcare stuff was cool until it took
six months to get your second vaccine
i got my vaccines here uh so that was
nice but the uh oh look at that just
like i got my phone in hawaii yeah no
canada's the best canada's beautiful
well there's got to be some ugly spots
to it yeah i've it's so big i've only
been to i've been in montreal which
you like montreal for sure they were
very rude honestly they were so there
you go
and when they a cobb i was i was
jaywalking in a very like very innocent
way like that was an innocent way of
jaywalking like i was looking and the
everyone started going so i just went
like i didn't
i wasn't leading them it wasn't a new
york way yeah i didn't do it knowing
that i was jaywalking i accidentally was
an accident it was an accidental crime
when the guy came to give me my ticket
and he found out i was american he was
so like juicily excited like his face
got so excited and
like
he was very excited to be like i got one
yeah i got one and then um
i
thought i'll get the pictures of this
because i i fought him like a juvenile
delinquent i was like so there's all
these pictures of me screaming at the
cop because i saw a fan with a camera
who had just said something about the
show i had gone to before or that he had
seen me on before because it was the
montreal comedy festival so i was like
and then i was like
because i was like if i get arrested for
jaywalking it's so good like being a
comedian so fun because you can you can
every thing is good yeah have you ever
been arrested maddie yeah
okay what happens in canada when you get
arrested they like go don't do that
don't do they tap you on your little
nose and they said on your way
um no i got arrested in high school
and then uh
it was like for we were at a hotel party
it was like semi-formal and we just got
into a fight with cops and we were all
getting kicked out of a hotel and then
uh
then my brother punched a cop
and then we got into a fist fight with
cops
that's the difference we would have just
got shot in america i feel like you
punched a cop yeah so you would yeah so
that's maybe a difference did the cops
have shields no punching no they didn't
have shields there wasn't a riot
they just have the bats the bobbies and
then in canada they do have like little
swords a long like um
chivalry kind of thing
so like when you're like when you're
doing a good deed a cop comes in yeah if
you were to wait for the light and not
jaywalk they would come over tap your
shoulders milady are you the here's i'm
this is what i'm nervous about yeah are
you
telling me the truth that i'm going to
be gullible or are you being silly and
i'm
canada do we have cops all have swords
right
answer him answer him answer annie the
answer annie they have they have pistols
they only have pistols like like not a
glock they have like a six like a
website it's like like a six shooter
like a pow-pow
stop it wow and then if they get close
combat they pull out the sword so then
they have they don't have to shoot first
a little more chill
so they if you if you you know you're if
you're spray painting a cop would just
walk up and like cut your hand off ah a
tap of the wrist a little slice slice
just to let you know it's like aladdin
days you know you steal it like a
grapefruit or like a persimmon you come
over cut your hand off or a loaf of
bread or a loaf of bread
annie i want to i want to ask about your
um wait buy sleepover i really literally
feel like you're wearing this guys will
you please buy sleepover by esther
because that's not it it's not it and i
feel guilty that i'm wearing like a
competing brand i'm not gonna tell you
what the [ __ ] brand is okay it's a
hoodie everybody has hoodies there's one
thousand million i know but you've not
met esther yet have you is she fragile
no
edit this out
i'm
let's just say she's not fragile annie
and i could just be dropped from a
hundred feet and probably still survive
yeah we're just rough [ __ ] yeah we're
worth [ __ ] so
yeah okay but esther is a very um on the
down low
probably would make the best cia agent
out of all of us yeah she's clear she's
a she's an intel queen and she asks
questions and you don't realize how much
you've already divulged yes so she's
very very crafty
about 10 years into our friendship i
realized she has never uh
told me any information except asked me
questions
and she prayed on my narcissism
she prayed on my narcissism i didn't it
took until there's every fragile moment
every vulnerable little thing every
trauma every little thing well
everyone's heard those i can't shut up
big esther we should probably let you
know that annie and i have been molested
in every single hole yeah and we talk
about it a lot so if for any reason
you're uncomfortable with it there's a
bell
for right next to you that's the banana
i like how you jerked it off a little
laughs
you went right sure i'm like if we get
too deep on the molest part
if we get too
just too much molestation talk yeah just
ring the bell we'll stop i love
molesters diddly talks that's great i
have some merch coming out that if you
haven't been molested i feel like you're
the weirdo no i i think i just feel i've
been doing a joke about how i feel bad
for like the two kids in my graduating
class that like didn't know all of our
teachers were molesters and like oh my
god
[Laughter]
i've had all the varieties of
molestation so has annie and all
different from from from preschool to
present it's just been a consistent
thing in our lives yeah before annie got
here she
um was telling me about a very very
serious dilemma she's having
um about two shamans that are giving her
conflicting information guys i have too
many shamans why do you have any wait
for me dilemma can you just read like a
meme
wait this one
this was given to me by a fan
guess the gender of the fan that gave
this to me oh are they it was a straight
white male
oh
my girlfriend came and i made fun of it
and then he gave it to me
and i love it and it actually i like it
because it it adds a shaman aspect to my
yeah
why was the thing hanging out of it like
well i've got what i thought we should
do what is that we should sage the uh no
here i can do the room we had a little
bit of a it was a wild episode a rough
episode last week it was yeah we were
all in goth and we we um laid out our
feelings we were all in golf yeah yeah
well esther was like
emo um
like my chemical romance
yeah um esther was like um
whoa
like she found out it was a goth episode
while she was walking by like a cvs and
she was like do they sell
shirts here and she like found one
t-shirt all right
what was that a crystal what is that a
box with a crystal in it this is
medicine animal cards we're gonna get to
the bottom of what's going on with you
maddie
we're gonna read you read me i'm so
excited to be read
and then the most holy of all items is
that a tampons yes i have never not
either been pmsing around my period in
every episode of this podcast
like absolutely genuinely not made up
like literally someone's got to i'm
wearing a nighttime pad right now just
so i don't ruin my new pants i am those
really expensive sunglasses are really
cheap i go to the grove and i get like
the the five for 25.
okay yeah i like i like a kiosk sunglass
situation because you're gonna sit on
them you're gonna lose them she's into
future cataracts
there's a look she's going is that
oh no because this is cataract's look
yeah because that's not polarized oh
because the cheap ones give you
batteries they don't do anything for you
yeah they just like so you look right
into the sun without no waiting for an
excuse to buy expensive sunglasses but i
was like uh you should just got it and
your beautiful green eyes and your
beautiful green eyes you guys they were
yellow last week
do you have expensive sunglasses always
i have expensive everything i love you
do look very expensive yeah i do yeah
that's my thing expensive though yeah i
think you're my style icon yeah
which car was yours out there
tahoe of course rental oh a rental yeah
i don't live here i rent cars what car
do you drive
um me yeah
uh i drive a denali what is that a truck
oh cool
i like a good truck what do you throw in
the back
uh
bodies
bodies dead deer
fences are you a fighter i mean i mean a
shooter a hunter a hunter no
are you a fighter are you a hunter you
aren't always the remnant it's like that
that's the only way i've ever seen
surviving the game with ice tea behind
homeless people what's the reverend is
the one where he's irreverent yeah where
they put the gunpowder where he gets bit
by the bear the bear yeah that's the
revenant i got the remnant the remnants
of the body the remnants of the eater
the sliced up thing yeah but that's how
i think hunting goes i call it maddie i
have hunted
what do you hunt i've hunted moose i've
hunted uh
deer
uh goats are you good at it no
no
no i'm loud i'm loud i'm like walking
around oh my god i like i'm making jokes
i'm talk like i'm like you just sit
there and like whisper to each other for
17 hours and you're like bro can we just
talk and then they're just like
okay
you're like you can hear it there's
nothing there's wind it's snowing i'm
cold you're definitely the same type of
hunter as i am yeah like i like walk out
i want to like shoot something like with
a uzi out of a car you know like just
drive into the woods and like spray the
woods hopefully get something you just
send out like a bunch of people to drag
it back that's the equivalent of
dynamite fishing yeah where you just
blow up the coral and see yeah also very
illegal guys don't do it don't blow
don't throw dynamite in we know you guys
are you've got your dynamite in your
hands and you're about to go do it we
know our audience okay
but put that dynamite away i'm 80s
put it back in your basement put it back
in your can i tell you why another
theory as to why i think um i look
amazing this week yeah yeah tell us
please expand on your beauty please
expand on your natural beauties hawaiian
shells and [ __ ]
well two things i think that the
universe gave me some
good snatched up good luck because i
rescued a turtle oh from a fishing line
is that why you're dressed like one
looking at this it's like turtle outfit
george pull up my
my rescue my video you say already
disgusted
and he hates turtles so i have to show
them turtles because i did a turtle
saving thing and they're gross and i had
to catch their eggs with their [ __ ]
juice and their eggs the [ __ ] juice
turtles have a lot of [ __ ] juice yeah
they ooze out these out
there we go we're taking about the the
line i'm on the left oh look at that and
then what it's a little guy did you
catch it
yeah we had to catch it
wait wait no but is that from you and
then you're saving it from yourself like
you just happened to be at a place where
there was a stuck turtle well no we were
fishing there oh
turtle pre-caught or did you
accidentally catch it and then save it
from yourself tell me the truth i'll
tell you the truth i looked down and
this turtle was lame it wasn't moving
anywhere and it couldn't use its left
arm and then i saw a giant fishing line
attached to it and i and so my buddy
caught it
and then we took the knife and then we
cut this thing from it from its arm when
esther comes back we have to check her
from f for fishing line she thinks she's
just covered in fishing line
her whole body but see we gotta we got
now i want to dive into why annie hates
turtles yeah i don't even hate it
like that's very cute okay when they get
a little bigger they're very um
what's the biggest turtle you say pour
this tar out of their eyes
it's just i'm not saying like they
should all die but if they died probably
a new animal would come that's cute well
tell maddie where you were do you think
the butterfly effect of the turtle dying
would just sprout a new beautiful animal
evolution works is it's not like
something dies and then nothing comes in
its place true
but so i um i think
that's a fact okay so i
god gives another animal to the planet
yeah i'm glad you brought god up because
god's great are you enlightened god is
good
we will be going back to these shames
i'm in a shaman dilemma but anyway i
maddie i when i was 17 i did a project
in costa rica with the sea turtle
project right it's called cocaine it's
just cocaine no i mean i did no drugs
i was just 17 fixing helping these sea
turtles but i was too young i had to
wear all black go out with these
flashlights with like a gel in front of
them it's red gel and then when the
turtles come out in the middle of the
night to lay their eggs they go into a
trance so once they're in their trance
they can't see you and then you had to
go under and catch their [ __ ] juice and
their eggs in a bag because there's
poachers and how delicious those eggs
must taste but i always think about this
scramble them up anyway
and then so then there was a hatchery
yes and so there were two duties you
would you would catch the [ __ ] juice
and then you'd also be on hatchery duty
to
so you put them in the hatchery and then
you would lay there all night
sit there and guard the hatchery from
the poachers who have weapons and
machetes i'm 17 years old little white
how did you get there
what you got like a brochure in high
school like there's people like this
how did you get like what sparked
getting to costa rica to grab [ __ ]
juice eggs from turtles and save them
with your life from the machete colors i
it was a whole program it was called
leap now
it was i don't know how my parents
[ __ ] found it my parents found any
shady situation they were like get you
out of here take her
you guys know i have a whole list
of
things that bog me down in life anxiety
bobby
he literally bogs her down like when
she's in the ocean
he grabs her and she falls to the bottom
so a lot of things interfere with my
happiness and um to get through the
rough days um i use betterhelp check out
betterhelp.com trash tuesday betterhelp
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist you can connect in a safe and
online environment and it's so
convenient
you can start communicating in under
just 48 hours you can send a message to
your counselor anytime and listen
they do regret that they do get them at
any time for me and i'm not kidding
that's a journal feature that i love the
best because then i can put down
whatever i'm feeling that week and to
this page yeah so by the time that my
therapist meets with me she's fully
aware of thoughts running through my
head difficulties that i've had that
week yeah when i'm in a spiral spin i'm
going to be messaging my counselor
immediately use that journal feature it
is essential um you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
all without ever having to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed which is such an important thing
because i know because if you're not
matched yeah when it's not a match it's
not a match you don't want to force it
then you got to go to therapy about the
therapist and you got to get a referral
to another it's a whole thing but with
better health it's like you can just
switch counselors and find your perfect
match it's also more affordable than
traditional therapy anything you share
in counseling anything you share is
confidential convenient it's
professional affordable in fact so many
people have been using betterhelp that
they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states you guys we
want you to start living a happier life
today as the listener you'll get 10 off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over 1 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's better help
h-e-l-p dot com slash trash tuesday
thank you to betterhelp for sponsoring
this episode
if there's anything annie and i know
it's about bad credit score and i'll
tell you something you know what um
childhood trauma is the gateway drug to
uh credit card debt is an adult
if you dread looking at your credit card
statements
trust us
you're not alone debt can feel crippling
but upstart can help you on your path to
financial freedom look how happy annie
is today guys so free they helped me so
much you guys it's a miracle i never
thought it would happen so many
americans experienced financial hardship
in the last year upstart can help you
regain your footing and get things back
on track upstart is a fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment listen and we
know that i have to fund my personal uh
crab leg addiction so and let's be real
annie and i are kind of dum-dums when it
comes to money so if we if you just give
us one payment to pay
we can do that it's too much to find all
the other ones find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com tuesday that's
upstart.com tuesday don't forget to use
our url to let them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com tuesday
i so i am set to do ayahuasca this
weekend
and i kind of don't want to do it i've
done it twice i've never had anything
but a beautiful experience wonderful
time but i have another shaman i have a
this guy's program who i watch and his
shaman
says to not do ayahuasca and i have just
randomly come across this video
that said do not do ayahuasca what are
you where did it take you both times
just to a nice place you were just like
it's hard i mean it's dark you go like
you go into the depths of your soul yeah
i mean it helped me a lot with like my
my worries about my dad's death i was
always like very worried about my dad's
age his uh inevitable death and then in
turn it was like my always being worried
about
the inevitable like bad things that are
going to happen and not being in the
moment and stuff and it did help me with
that to realize that being truly
powerless
well kind of yeah but then also the
power knowing that you there's no
control and to detach and to not you
know to just love carpe diem it's there
and i was and i felt very like
that i was starting to acknowledge the
love that was around me that i wasn't
seeing
the second time i said what do i need to
do for my to bring my career to the next
level and i saw powerpuff girls three
girls yeah because and it said you need
to get your girl audience going there
you go and that was like two years ago
and then you [ __ ] black and had an ulcer
and then called me and then i had to get
into ketamine and get an ulcer
to contact me would you get the black
[ __ ] from from like pepto ketamine no
yeah from all the ketamine
well it was were you doing you like
drooling
there esther was annoying me i had an
ulcer
or i was doing ketamine
caused the black [ __ ] i had um like
there's a grinding noise outside that
makes me feel like you've got a black
[ __ ] coming
you hear that sound but also my
apartment was under construction it was
just like a lot was going on oh and i
just got a [ __ ] ulcer but because i
[ __ ] blood and she had talked to who did
you talk i had just [ __ ] blood myself
yeah so we really bonded over shedding
blood and we talked for five hours on
our first conversation your first
conversation was five hours about
shooting blood we've never gone under
three hours we've never unless like
literally something uh like our
conversation ended today because i got
here yeah yeah so the black ship brought
you together the black ship brought us
together and then after that it's like
we've just been
attached at the [ __ ] i think mm-hmm
yeah we were we're slimiest plot twins
[ __ ] twins is nice
twins
have you ever done ayahuasca no
do you do like mushrooms and stuff like
that no i'm so obsessed oh yeah that's
right that's right yeah always have been
no no no no no no you're not you're not
suffered by not doing drugs no
people i used to do everything yeah but
you never did eyelashes though no i
never got there i never had to find
myself
yeah or like build a fantasy thing i
don't understand ayahuasca i know i
don't understand like the whole like
finding yourself thing i don't
understand that i i guess maybe i'm like
very grounded in who i am so i just
never i don't get caught up with the or
my brain doesn't ever go to a place
where i need to like figure something
out yeah where i've already dealt with i
think i figured things out well you
don't have to like you don't always have
to be like going back and figuring out
where things are coming from that's kind
of why i'm like apprehensive of doing it
this time because i'm not in one of
those searchy places right now i just
want to feel that
no i don't i already signed up for it
yeah right now i'm no i'm it's like i
just already bought the plane ticket and
show me i'm just about amish when it
comes to drugs yeah um i've never done
anything like hallucinogenic no acid no
shrooms no i used to smoke a lot of weed
when i was younger and i drink maybe
three times a year and that's it i'm
pretty i don't even drink caffeine right
i'm a big big square but
all of this to say that i don't have to
throw the [ __ ] banana though yes i
don't look at like ayahuasca and the
hallucinogens i've done as like they're
not like recreational drugs like i'm not
you're not doing them to get high like
if you're doing them yeah you're gonna
be
sorely upset yourself right no you need
like a shaman there's a whole thing like
it's just one on one or you go like
groups there's a group that i go with i
mean you can go one on one you go like
joshua tree um i did go to
the desert the first time i went it was
like in the desert outside of san diego
yeah and then i'm going to like the
woods in chicago which is where i went
before the woods and it's just my my
shaman is from brazil or he's from south
africa but he lives in brazil and he
trained in people how much does that
cost to have somebody spiritually
enlighten you
it's like over the years it's gone from
like 400 to 600 i think there's a little
complication
and you do it for like a whole weekend
and i know people that do it in like
apartments in new york and stuff but
it's i've gotten really like i've never
had a negative like
feeling around it i've always gone into
it very open and very excited and i'm
very trusting of my shaman and his
expertise but just seeing these videos
of this other guy saying not to do it
just got and i just have never had
any hesitation to it but i am feeling
like i really like the work i'm doing
with just hypnosis and you're doing
hypnosis yeah i'm doing a lot of
self-hypnosis
wow
where does that bring you it's just i've
just dropped a bunch of things like the
thing i've mentioned on here a lot which
is like the biggest
get for me so far is that i no longer
clench my jaw which is something i was
doing since i was a child so it's like
i've got i'm getting rid of a lot of my
like fight or flight stuff that i've
been in
and really like
yeah it's been really cool it's been
amazing but so now that i realize i can
do these things without like diving into
the depths of like i can dive into the
depths of my soul like through
meditation like that i kind of i'm like
[ __ ] do you meditate every day
i do hypnosis every day you do hypnosis
every day yeah i didn't do mine yet
today but that's a while that's so cool
the [ __ ] when i was a kid i remember
we had a hypnosis or a hypnotist come to
our high school not a kid but
i remember my mom being like you do not
go up there and you do not like the
things that i remember as like a
teenager like i was never my mom was
always very adamant about never letting
anyone crack my back yeah and and like
never do hypnotic did you grow up
religious really yeah religious yeah i
grew up like mormon oh okay yeah i was
in it for like born into it for like 13
years wow we left when i was like 13.
interesting that's an interesting time
to do you then just excommunicate
yourselves well yeah well my sister got
excommunicated well we were we moved
like a uh from province so like away out
of the one state where we grew up in
like dartmouth was a massive
like uh fellowship big church lots
hundreds of people every sunday like
packed house every sunday it's like
super bowl and [ __ ] it and then when my
family got it we moved there was no
church there was like one church and
you'd show up and there's like two
families and then all of a sudden it's
just when you leave something it just
becomes like indifferent and then you're
just like ah and i just my dad stopped
going one day and then all of a sudden
we didn't have to go and then all of a
sudden my dad drank like a non-alcoholic
beer and we're all just like what's
happening yeah and then also my dad
started drinking beer and then i was
just like what's happening do you have a
nostalgia for um churches like do you
feel like when you walk into one you
have like a childhood nostalgia or a
feeling that you get like huh this is
like familiar
yeah well i went to like i got kicked
out of public school so then i
in high school so then i went to a
catholic high school and it was just
like i don't know when i walk into
churches now i just feel nothing
kind of like i don't feel oh they're
beautiful they're beautiful i always
like like looking at them like i i feel
like i come from like nice millwork you
know stained glasses are cool yeah great
milwaukee great stained glasses for sure
the feeling that i get because i was
raised catholic right having to go to
math get my confirmation being baptized
all of that stuff
but when i go back home and i go to
midnight mass i get very emotional i
kiss the statue of jesus's feet i light
the candles and i'm like i'm an atheist
yeah but i kiss his feet you feel it's
like
muscle memory yeah it's muscle memory
you've been scared into kissing feet
yeah some white dude maybe that's the
maybe that's why where foot fetishes
came from yeah it's kissing god's feet
now do you um
do you think it's because it's like
bringing you back to a nostalgic time in
your childhood it's reminding you of
maybe your dad i think it reminds me of
like a serenity of like my family being
together during christmas time because
it's called simbangabi where like at the
beginning of december you start going to
mass at midnight and your family all
sort of walks there together
you light candles yeah yeah it's like
god rave and you get to be up late
that's so exciting yeah when you're
young kids so i think i i feel like some
sense of excitement because of that but
not because like i super love jesus or
anything like that yeah that's how i'm
reading it yeah i don't believe in the
god but it's do you believe in any like
what about like people who believe in
like three thousand gods because i i'd
be more likely to to be into that i
don't believe in any gods the uh
i believe in like a higher power i
believe something that is i believe in
spirit i believe in like you
and you and me and every you know like i
believe what my religion was was quakers
and those little lights and everyone or
any girl quaker quaker okay beats and
stuff you know who um that's amish but
do you know um wait churning buddy it's
like flowers you know what my higher
power wasn't a why uh shaquille o'neal
from kazam
everyone was so mad at me
like i sent an email gotta go you know i
used to pray to him you're just doing
your gratitude list in the morning pray
to him with his genie outfit
you're like shazam i would say oh my
shack instead of oh my god
everyone was like you're gonna drink
again i was like no i'm not but i will
do ayahuasca
there you go george has stuff for us oh
no
here we have barnett's mega sours the
sourest candy in the world now some
would say toxic waste is the sours candy
but we've done our research these are
actually sourer
than toxic well what's the goal do we
have to eat the whole thing straight
face poker face yeah ready
i got blue i got green
i'll change what are you orange i'll do
blue i'll do all right let's all do blue
we all got blue blue blue okay blue pill
pill
okay let's what you just suck it mm-hmm
yeah that's what i always say do you
just suck
it
this seems like a sour
for how long
it's salty
why is it salty
this is disgusting
[Laughter]
does it get sweet at any point is it
does it sweet on the inside it's just
foamy if you eat it
why is it foamy oh it's disgusting oh
why did it foamy yeah exactly eat it
chew it up really like a lot of little
chews really work the foam why did it
jizz in my mouth yeah i was like that's
like turtle juice
that's a turtle juice bomb it didn't
jizz on me oh maybe you waited too long
because i've already been just done i
know
chock full of jokes um
maddie what are your thoughts on
[ __ ] in the shower
like recreational or just like for use
well i hear that people
do it for use
no that's gross
that's not nice for anything especially
i have like um hairy thighs probably
like it would catch the [ __ ]
it's a lot more cleanup for me and then
you know what you push it along with
your foot and then yeah what do you stop
it down and then you're stopping down
the [ __ ] the the like play-doh yeah
so
so here's so brown people have their own
mythology
and have our own like urban myths and
one of our urban myths
she gets a tan and now she's really
pushing the brown agenda
so we tell each other that white people
should shower that it's a hobby that's
why people show the shower
i've never met shits in the shower i've
never not pissed in a shower ever once
even when it's not on i piss in the
shower every time
the warm water
it's always after i wash my hair and i
wash my hair and condition and i just
feel so nice and i'm just like ugh
it's not the first thing i do
and i just let it go i like to pee on my
boyfriend yeah piss parties are nice
water sports the best feeling is if
you're in the ocean with a wetsuit to
pee in your website
yes and you just you're swimming in that
warm piece it's that it gets cold it
doesn't no no not in a five millimeter
it just stays there it keeps you warm
it's insulated like a yeti cooler now
okay so i like to okay so i always have
to pee my boyfriend and i are moving
today currently wow i this just happened
so successful you're not even picking a
box up the lord had to
um
happen to move the day
to and the exact time the movers came to
when i came was george lord
no no it wasn't this was already set and
then things got messed up in the
apartment so they had to push it where
are you moving we're moving to the same
apartment complex but with now it's two
bedroom two bath so now i don't have to
pee while my boyfriend's [ __ ] oh i
would always have to pee in the tub
that's so nice i had this one bedroom
apartment
uh my wife and i or whatever trishy and
[ __ ]
it was so small it was like like smaller
than well maybe same size as this
and like you could [ __ ] you could see
yourself shedding if you were any if the
door was open like anywhere in the
apartment you could see the person
[ __ ] or using the washroom or
anything and it was like all we wanted
to do was get a place big enough to like
not see your partner like [ __ ] because
this is like you know using the water
it's like whatever it's not like a
complete turn off but like always it's
always i have an open bathroom door
policy in my relationships you have to
we mean just relationships you mean face
time yeah that's true i'm always yeah
but you know you should be pretty fast
on our we go we go we we [ __ ] together
i should be together with all my yeah
always yeah you facetime your guy
friends a lot yeah it's but that's it
well it's just nice everyone's relaxed
instead of like just doom scrolling you
just call your buddy you're like hey
yeah you can't ever be you can't even be
in a moment by yourself just being
normal not looking at your phone or
talking to a friend getting validation
and just [ __ ] regularly you have to you
know you sit down look at your phone for
two seconds squish out and then you
[ __ ] call a homie dude that's the way
i don't get your first push out so you
don't look stressed
and then and your second push you can be
on the phone but the first initial is
you're a strain though you got to mute
yourself when you strain i've never
strained oh huh i just can't
that's become asian squat well annie you
know my method of [ __ ] is the most
efficient way you got like the step up
thing
well here's the thing you have to look
around the corner
so when we were in the philip when i was
growing up you learned to [ __ ] like this
because our toilets are set up a little
different in the province you kind of
have to [ __ ] in the in the rocks and the
bang bang yeah
so this is the correct way to [ __ ] so
you put your legs up like yeah so that's
the same as the step so your body's in
the push so it's been it's been do you
stand on the toilet to [ __ ]
now yeah i don't anymore because i think
i no longer have to because i spent so
many years [ __ ] like this so it's
like it's just um it slides out yeah my
my um anatomy has now sort of like um
upped a level so that i can now [ __ ]
without straining now is childbirth
easier for the filipina um i don't know
we're going to see about my my fish come
baby
baby soon nine months maybe it's even
sooner who knows how fast the
gestational gestational period of a fish
that's when i'm giving birth i am i have
to make a monster wait weeks away oh my
god will you birth my fish baby i've
already done three he birth his own baby
oh i was just gonna ask that yeah home
birth homeboy
how old are they uh max like five
rizzo's almost three ozzy she's
gonna be one in october they're great
names yeah good job what's your wife's
name trisha tricia trish trish trisha
and maddie i like maddie the choice of
maddie out of all the
maddie's
it's the best one yeah 100 out of all my
kids they're good names but my name's
better yes well of course you have to be
the best
one of the biggest bummers of adulting
is having to
quit cereal
ah
what a
joy it was to just be a kid and eat the
cereal you enjoyed just diving into it
not knowing that you were lactose
intolerant just diarying everywhere but
so worth it the good news though you no
longer have to give it up because
there's magic spoon that's right
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 13
to 14 grams of protein and only 4 net
grams of carbs in each serving only 140
calories a serving it's keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
and gmo free
and they have all the flavors the cocoa
fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry cinnamon cookies
and cream even annie and maple waffle
and you don't need to have your protein
shake anymore that boring
disgusting thick drink you can now get
your protein in your cereal come on
subscribe today to flavors you love and
you can get cereal shipped to your
doorstep not to mention saving more than
25 on every order you can choose four
flavors you love edit your subscription
to switch it up and keep yourself
stocked up on cereal we are all trying
to eat better but healthy breakfast
doesn't have to be so boring magic spoon
has the amazing flavors you love but
without all the bad stuff go to
magicspoon.com tuesday5 or use our promo
code tuesday5 at checkout to get five
dollars off your order and try it today
remember if you subscribe to magic spoon
you get five dollars off on top of the
25 savings from subscribing and magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's backed with a hundred percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked
remember subscribe and get your
delicious guilt-free cereal on the
regular at magicspoon.com
tuesday5 and use the code tuesday five
and save big thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode
what do you how do you think truly yeah
bobby would be in the pocket during a
home birth
do you think he would be playing a video
game yeah he would be indifferent he
would be indifferent he'd have his
headphones on like world of warcraft or
[ __ ] how's your phone you're probably
attempting my boyfriend's moving so it's
like i gotta make sure i put mine on
airplane mode i guess you didn't [ __ ] it
i know but i was moving i'm like pretty
famous
i think he'd do this i think he would
have about a 10 second period of really
giving an earnest shot at participating
in the home birth and then he'd be like
oh i can't do it babe i can't believe i
got the umbilical cord uh i don't think
i don't think he'd be present for that
either i don't think he's like i don't
like the blood but what if it changed
him what if he like what if it was
turning i didn't think i was ready and
then and the it's like one of those
things i didn't i went to like the
birthing class with like mega doula and
like all of a sudden did you hear dreads
nah she was she was hippies owned though
but she [ __ ] she did like over 900
births wow and and because i was like at
one point right before the birth i was
just like yo like trash like what is it
it's like midwife this that like how
many home like how many people are gonna
be in the in the crib and she was just
like it's you and the and you and the
midwife and like the doula and i was
just like
what
what you know because it was the with
the first one in a tub
no we all dry like all on her back
cookie tray like a baking tray wrapped
in a towel for lower back support
wow
bun in the oven for real that's it
that's all that happens
but it's amazing i think whatever i
think bobby would be great in the pocket
i think he would do good have you ever
seen him in the pocket i haven't but i
can imagine
he would find the place he needed to go
mentally and he would zone in and get
into it
he once told me he was like great if you
ever get pregnant i'll just make sure to
book as many road dates as possible
that's nice
so i was like oh thank you thank you so
much thank you thank you bob that's
great thank you for potassium you guys
we have banana breakfast on this one
yeah let's get the blood
[Music]
let's do it let's get tingly legs what's
going on we just got a little i get
tingly legs i cramp up easy so hence the
potass this is so nice mm-hmm i know
it's great right this is a really nice
podcast
is it the nicest one you've been on i
think so because it's always like
one-on-one or like it was oh taco bell
was really nice
i think it's just like
i don't know we have the sucker thing i
need you to say we're better than rogan
yeah thank you
i'm not gonna get canceled by three
national newspapers coming on this show
it's fine
my mom
did not like me being on that dude my
mom
sent me a message where she goes
oh my god danny i'm so proud of you you
got mentioned in this article
and it's an article about how since
rogan joined spotify his numbers have
gone down i'm like mom this is like a
bad article
they're like you were like one of the
comedians the second annie letterman saw
a low return in her it's like also
that's actually not true i got like over
30 thousand followers every time yeah
they're so great i'm like where are the
numbers you're crunching you
know i thought it was gonna be it's so
funny i thought it was gonna be
like i i think joe's like a double-edged
sword obviously for some reason but i
think
it is a um
i thought it was going to like blow some
[ __ ] up it really just kept
i got like 1500 i think i lost more
followers really oh i got so many
followers i don't know i but i i don't
know i
who cares i've been friends with him for
forever so i don't i don't think people
are like surprised that i was on the
show
there was a lot of people that didn't
know me before saw me i mean i did as a
fight companion yeah
rogan wasn't there but it was his studio
i don't like outward dick pics that's
the saddest thing i've ever heard
without bro you're like all i got going
on a podcast was dick pics
oh my god
[ __ ] a ton of dick pics oh my goodness i
got some dick pics too but it's if did
he did you get a picture with him and he
posted it or was it no i was on the day
that he was like getting ousted by the
white house for being like the new face
of like anti-vaxx
so i was like on that day like when that
was happening i was literally on that
day and then i posted a photo and i was
just like boom
i just had like it was like
yeah it was like
like every paper
in canada it was just like because we
were making jokes about some stuff and
and it wasn't good
yeah it was just like they're always
good jokes are always good but it was
just like it was like when the
newspapers got involved i was just like
huh
i was like really
okie dokie you want i need a statement
i was just like
what no no no you didn't give a
statement i uh
well it was a scenario because
it was uh i didn't argue enough
uh when he was like we were just talking
about like it was right after there was
um
police there was a funeral in like
montreal
like a secret funeral and the police is
that why someone jaywalked and got hit
by a car no somebody died it's a funeral
it's not a jaywalk you got hit by a car
and died they got hit by a car and died
and but it was it was the police went in
and like raided it the funeral because
of the pandemic was like you guys can't
be in here oh my goodness and so rogan
was just touching on that being like yo
like what's up with this [ __ ]
canadian government like you can't have
funerals you're like well no there's a i
don't i don't [ __ ] know and whatever
and i just didn't argue with it i didn't
know what them and i didn't argue
because i hate when i don't know
anything i'm not gonna like i don't know
i was just kind of like no and i got in
trouble for like yeah yeah my way
through a conversation yeah but yeah
i thought for three hours to draw i
talked about aliens you would have
gotten in trouble
no matter anything it doesn't matter but
that's the thing so i had to literally i
gave a statement so like i was just like
sorry not even sorry but i was just like
i could have sorry sorry i could have i
could have argued more yeah
it was like
i was just like ah
i don't know
i'm sorry i was just like you're making
me do the canadian i just like i'm sorry
i'm just like i'm a clown okay i'm here
to make jokes i know i don't like
boogers and like talk about yeah
cooking food and like
doing drugs i'm like i'm not anything
i'm like the dumb fun guy
maddie what would happen if you could
come um please
it depends
like i think there's um
are there is some things you could fold
there's a whole book
there's cooking yeah yeah yeah look up
the book it's like we talked about just
a dash because we were talking about
eaton come and it was um there's a whole
book about semen cookery
and uh
recipes and they're like and throw some
cumin ester's going to finally start
cooking yeah semanology is that it or
what's the natural harvest
oh and you put a flan
i like that because it's deceiving dolce
de leche with some jizz i would love a
dulce de leche with some cons some kind
just come but i i feel like if you were
doing that just make something really
nice and throw some [ __ ] on top
like raises it through a little glaze or
like why cooks it's like
you know it's like adding alcohol and
you burn the alcohol off it's like right
like you know it's just like you want
the jizz just chuck the jizz on top how
would i approach this do i go to any
rando and say hi
you're like eating a sandwich i like you
know you go to ear one and you walk
outside and be like oh my god you have
to make bobby cuck cakes yeah cupcakes
making cupcakes
that's another man's semen i jerked them
off i got it yeah
cream pies cream pies cupcakes
cream pies cupcakes
that does well
i'm sure you could sell a lot of
cupcakes
you're a genius
we have our merch we have our new name
yeah cupcake welcome to cupcakes
trash tuesday's out it's trash
cupcakes is back
is there reviews yeah three it's four
and a half stars dude this book is like
full of [ __ ]
just check out a review read a review
for the pictures alone are you [ __ ]
can't put this book down way too sticky
it says my gay cousin and his boyfriend
got this
in a white elephant party and they
threatened to make us
a whole dinner using the recipes from
this 11 out of 10 would buy again what's
a white elephant party and there's also
another one well when you're talking
about comments sounds like a different
thing but i don't know why it's just
when you it's like when you like a
pollyanna or is that what it's called
thank you for this recommendation maddie
yeah you said i like you you could
probably get that and um you know get
make a couple of recipes get uh bob bob
[ __ ] i just want a whole array of bobby
drapes i don't want just his [ __ ] he has
like a single thick dollop it's not
going to cover a whole pie just a pinch
out hey it's a pinch let's drink more
water yeah he's a little dehydrated
drink water
spray it everywhere i like a little bit
more propulsion than that yeah like ah a
little bit of a champagne celebration i
never get that todd takes an unnamed um
hair product that i'm not gonna say
unless they sponsor us
and it does work but one of the side
effects is that your jizz is like more
clear he has not had that celery that's
the best one
what celery eat like two heads of celery
like two full things of celery
24 hours before you're going to party
and then jizz town but wait it's morges
extra jews just all of it yeah it's
great for all of the jizz every aspect
of it even for us healthier it's
more do i want not milk here but like
not like more volume more volume maybe
liquidity
i think i want less volume less volume i
like the volume
grass is always greener you have too
much juice she wants i know i don't give
you bobby
switch your roots what twins forever see
no harm twins that's what tt stands for
[ __ ] twins so um when i first started to
get to know annie she
was telling me some pretty wild stories
but one of my favorite stories has to do
with um her school nurse but do you
remember what it is there's two stories
right so when she today she goes all
right i have school nurse written down
and i go that could be two one of two
things
one of two could be high school or
college i'm gonna go for college because
college was the most the funniest thing
that's ever happened to me right i got
crabs in college okay the adam sandler
had the movie um the longest yard was in
town they were filming it right and i
lived in in santa fe new mexico
and the movies would come would be like
insane when everyone would come out
there was like unbelievable
so
all these guys were out there i started
hooking up with like one of the
assistant directors i met him at a party
or whatever he was like you know 30 and
i was 21.
and um like an la guy and he was like
taking me out to these dinners into the
spawn stuff and then i go out of town
for a week
he's still on set or whatever i start to
itch in my [ __ ] nether regions i go
what is itching
what is this i get home my mom is in
town visiting me i go mom something's
wrong grand army i'm itching i'm itching
and then um i look down i see that i see
things crawling on me i go that is
[ __ ] so crabs are actual crabs yes
they're actual crabs
so then i go
i go to the school nurse i go to the
school nurse yeah and i go i have crab
she gets shoes no you don't have guys
i'm like i have [ __ ] crabs and this
one okay
she took it she took a second look and
then she found out of crabs now six
months later maybe even two years later
okay time has passed
i've gotten rid of the crabs at this
point it took two years no no
because time has moved forward the crabs
are and are an ancient are in the
the they're in the rearview mirror yeah
can't you imagine them they just
i missed them i actually was so sad when
they went away they were so funny you
know what i knew i was gonna be a
comedian i loved having lice as a kid
when i would use the suit it's like a
really fine toothed comb and i would pop
them oh the joy i would i my mom and i
still talk about it like i never have
should we get lice again right or
cracked all the time i've never had
crabs either but i've had bedbugs but
i'm at whole foods two years later
after the crabs
and i i go to i go to the guacamole
thing i reach for the same chip i touch
hands with a woman i look up i go oh my
god you were the school nurse that
diagnosed me with crabs
and she goes oh yeah i remember you
and then i forfeited i gave her this
here's a good here's the chat she was
like i'm good
i
i think that's um what they made a movie
um out of that i think so serendipity
with john cusack
right i think that's exactly what it is
either that or like the boathouse yeah
yeah wait there's a boathouse that was a
lake house house with sandra bullock
yeah wait there's boathouse is the new
one what's the one that i just saw in
the movie theater the dark house is it
good what is it or the night house it
was bad
by the way going to the movie sucks
yeah the movies need to like they need
to let you do more i went to one have
you been to the movie theaters where
they like let you lay down yeah but they
let you lay down but only so far so i'm
sitting with my boyfriend and then they
have this like this barrier here so you
lay down and then it's like so i gotta
like literally every every [ __ ] hand
job is a reach around because you gotta
go on the thing you gotta go around and
then it's like i just wanna cuddle on
his [ __ ] chest yeah so then you have
to sit up and do it it's just like
and then it's so cushy that you're like
there's so much covet in this like
you're like oh it's so squishy and
it probably captured all the covet from
the person before me yeah and then it's
just like and they bring you the food
they're kind of interrupting the meal or
the movie and
it just i don't know the popcorn's still
good but
you gotta do something bad i have to do
something because everyone's been at
home depressed for two years
but more so in canada but i think it's
just like because but i think you guys
over here it's just i don't know like
everyone doesn't even want to go back
yeah yeah nobody even cares anymore
maddie did you draw any of your tattoos
me yeah uh
yeah oh an inside hand yeah did that
hurt yeah this is the worst one i've
ever had and they wear off or no i don't
because you use them more no people just
don't get them because they hurt yeah
well just take a pencil and touch your
palm it's crazy
last time i went to vegas some guy
hunted me down
klyla clil it's me brian do you remember
you tattooed me three years ago and he
lifted his leg oh no and dear god it was
the ugliest tattoo i've ever seen how
did you do it
back when i was like a shop girl my
ex-boyfriend was a tattoo oh okay and i
looked at it i was like i am so sorry
horror most horrible thing i've ever
seen yeah the shit's [ __ ] but i wanted
to get blasted in the neck um what are
what is the station in this area don't
do anything stop what do you mean no i
love neck tattoos don't you have a nice
neck
if you don't have a lot of tattoos like
don't cover your [ __ ] up
that's nice yeah don't get a neck do
whatever you want to do really i just
like i don't [ __ ] oh my god she's
gonna get a [ __ ] neck tattoo yeah
what are you gonna do like like just
like a design no i wanted to extend my
filipino tribal into yeah okay i guess
so my boyfriend told me he doesn't think
i can hear you you would look good with
like face like yes
like a neck tattoo would look really
good on you actually burn it out um my
my boyfriend told me that he doesn't
think i could handle the pain of a
tattoo you have zero see that i wish i
had none it's cool to have none right
yeah it's way cooler to have because
every jabroni has tattoos now it's just
like i don't know
he's a joy boy he doesn't need staging
no he's pure on the inside no i i had
like the most depressing time of my life
i think the last six weeks or some [ __ ]
six weeks i i've never felt depressed in
my life ever
and and try ayahuasca
and uh that smells nice and and um
sage
the uh and i just felt depressed and not
happy with anything i was doing and i
never felt it before was there a trigger
was there something that happened that
you can maybe sort of like i think i
built up a business
where i have to put so much output you
know like it's it's a lot to do what
everyone does right yeah you know just
output
and give and give and give and give and
give and then be criticized about
everything that you give but are you
reading comments where are you finding
the criticism no i don't read comments
i'm very good at like not reading both
sides like i don't i don't like to get
gassed up and i don't like to be torn
down how do you find out about the
criticism i just it's how i feel
it's it's i i feel
more just like the amount of stuff i'm
like i want to just get to the point
where everything is about how much work
you're doing right like how oh i got a
show on netflix i got a thing here i got
a [ __ ] tour i got books i got [ __ ]
glue and it just like turns into i i
don't know i think i'm just like my
brain is still in a point where i'm like
i just flipped on myself and like was
just like you're not punk you're a loser
you're a poser [ __ ] you you're just
doing stuff for money and i was just
like i am doing stuff for money but i
also just i don't know it just sunk in
deep in my own head yeah like without
it's not about the comments you started
like overthinking your i just
overthinking my yeah and my thing like
my intentions and just like what i'm
doing what i'm putting out there and
like
it's um i don't know and then it just
went deep and i was just like felt like
i never felt like before and i cancelled
all this i cancelled like always a
series and like all this other [ __ ] i
was just like i'm out on all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
and then i just did i quit everything
and then now i'm just gonna start
figuring out some stuff cool but i was
just like i don't know it was just like
a thing where i hit a wall and then the
wall i was just like this is so crazy
because i think with the pandemic and
stuff it was just like you know how
everyone lost like i had like
you know it was it's like everything
everyone lost yeah and then and then
rebuilt and then how did you rebuild and
at what costs and what did it take to
rebuild and then and then you're like
wait i was just rebuilding all this
other stuff but zero like spirit [ __ ]
yeah and like not taking care of myself
and working every day to make sure that
i build stuff that isn't taken away
and then and it's just like i did i just
think i got burnt and then and then sad
and i'm never sad and then that was the
thing where i was just like
like i talked to my therapist i was like
i think i'm genuinely depressed and then
she's like let's do a depression test
i'm like let's
and i did it she's like you're not
depressed i was like perfect
why she's like you're just sad and i'm
just like oh okay
and then i was just like i'm just going
to take time off she's like take a week
off and then i took a week off and i was
like i feel better
and then i came out here it took like a
couple days to just like ride
motorcycles and stuff out and whatever
and [ __ ] it and then i was like i feel
really good
i just needed to get out of my own
little world that you you create these
little worlds and then you get burnt and
then you're just like i hate my little
world that i like i i've never i've
always never wanted a job and that's why
i went and did my own thing and did all
my [ __ ] and like you know i have my own
production company i have all my own
[ __ ] i don't have a boss you know and
i'm just like i like not having a boss
but then i put the pressure on of
doing everything we we can also very do
a great job of burning ourselves out
yeah because we we think we've created a
world where we don't have to answer to
anybody you have to answer to the world
yeah exactly and so it's like now the
pressure is on to sort of just always
keep
moving yeah and kind of proving the
theory that like you know i i create
this is all mine but
sometimes what's all yours really is a
big weight to carry on your back if you
want to be depressed kalila has some
poems
oh yeah i have some i kept all my
teenage emo poems so if you ever um just
want to have a good cry dabble in the
darkness yeah i'll slip it into your dm
i need a couple
yeah my the opposite happened to me a
couple weeks ago um with my therapist
right she was basically like
i'm i'm referring you to psychiatrists
it's time for meds again yeah because
you are
a blue [ __ ] like you are so blue and so
down like a good sixty percent of your
life now do you feel like since you went
to hawaii do you feel different okay so
here you got healed by the ocean
i realize um and i know this is gonna
sound so
cringy
but
when i submerge my body and when i can
feel when i don't hear the noise of the
outside world and i am so hyper focused
on my own breath
and i don't hear there is not a noise in
my head
i feel that i am relieved of all of
those feelings that i feel on land and i
did that every day for eight days
straight and i feel
baptized
and now i'm like i don't not to say that
those feelings won't come back
but it's quitting the body i'm quitting
she's going to live at sea
with her husband i thought about that i
was like maybe i'm just a seafarer and i
just need to you know leave do you float
do you do that float [ __ ] no i i
submerge i go like 25 30 feet down and i
just like
no i mean i mean like the float capsules
like why i never do that that you mean
the uh were you laying the salt things
sensory deprivation tanks where it's
like
you get to that sound of the nothingness
right but it's so i've never done it i
don't want to have to pay you know what
i mean i wouldn't like go to the ocean
well you paid for a flight and a
[ __ ] yeah you paid a couple bucks to
get down
listen once our schedules like honestly
the scheduling is is the reason it's
crazy right now is because with stand up
it's a weekend job with with acting
which esther's doing now it's a it's a
weekday job so now we're like our
scheduling is crazy yeah when our
scheduling is better we can schedule
around you going and having these
moments as much as you want but right
now we're gonna have a moment of honesty
i think that so much of my existence in
the last eight years my identity has
been tied to bobby and i sort of um
you know i live for the man i love him
so deeply but i think that i stopped i
forgot how to like live for myself a
little bit and sort of tap into
other parts of myself um
and that's where i think it comes from
it's like you
forget that you are a whole entity
you know irrespective of your
relationship with somebody and that
yeah being underwater i think that's the
hardest thing
yeah you know like that's the hardest
thing is to maintain that
oneness and to have that self-awareness
of being okay with your whole self and
finding your whole self and
you know continuously
every day showing up for yourself
you know living under shadows of
whatever the [ __ ] you're living under
because everyone is under a thing you
know
whatever it is everyone is under a thing
yeah of course everyone's under a thomas
something
i'm not
everything guys
she's the best number one guys i don't
want to brag
she number one she's a goddamn trophy
perfect trophy i'm perfect
well thank you so much for coming to do
this big aster week hey big esther's
here big esther's house is always open
to you yesterday's house that's great
well big esther come back big hazard
would love to go back he's going to be
when i when i got the ask you know big
george
oh my god big annie big annie
i was so i was like more excited than
tiger belly to be honest
and more excited because i was just like
i don't know i was like you guys don't
have guests often no and then and then
and then i showed up and i was like oh
i'm a filler but that's fun
but i'm still just like
you know
i think it's really cool to be here and
to be uh trash-talked or whatever the
[ __ ] you guys call
but i think you know what we are yeah
just [ __ ] we can do it in depth next
time we could do a more in-depth
sobriety what led us there
how did you become such a big comedian
what's that stand up is so hard for just
normal people i just feel like a nine to
five so much harder whenever people like
obviously you don't have them but like
when audience members come up and like
you're so brave i'm like you're a brave
[ __ ] with a nine to five yeah you're
brave yeah
it's i always look at it like i always
say that stand-up's like an ocean job
and
and i think that your guys what you guys
do too is the same you know the living
in the entertainment business and stuff
but it's like it's an ocean job and i do
this because i was like thrown into the
sea and i would never like live in a
land job like a nine to five knowing
where things are coming from what's
happening like it's just i can't exist
there so i like the turbulence of like
being sucked under on top of a wave like
i like that sort of chaos and i think
now
that i've been doing about 12 years and
i am starting to
like get my groove and really connect
with an audience i'm able to be more
grounded in that
because all anxiety and all fear is past
or future thought right here's nice
we're doing good right here and if we're
not we're a little too busy to worry
we're [ __ ] figuring something out you
know trash tuesday yeah
well the name might change so what about
um again
what is called now well it's trash
tuesday now it's trash tuesday now but
it will be changed mm-hmm yeah to big
house
big
we don't have a budget for a new chair
yeah
she sits on my belly like my baby
gotta figure out if you're a top or
bottom
both and if you're the top god i would
love to see it i would love to see that
bob and weave well thanks for having me
on thank you maddie this is good
yes brother
bye guys we'll see you next week losers
[Music]
you